RETO MEIER: Welcome to "Build
Out," where real engineers face
off building fake products.
Today's challenge--
The Virtual Earth.
I'm Reto Meier, the perpetual
winner, which means this is--
COLT MCANLIS: --Colt
McAnlis, the only one of us
who's actually built
a virtual world.
So whose earth rocks?
Find out now on "Build Out."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You know the Northern
Hemisphere points up, right?
RETO MEIER: Not in my world.
Southern Hemisphere forever.
Influenced by Neal
Stephenson's global Metaverse,
my virtual earth
builds on Google Earth
to build a fully interactive,
global, virtual environment,
based on real-time
updates returned
for millions of drone-based
sensors deployed
all across the physical world.
We collect environmental
data from millions
of basketball-sized
autonomous drones
with environmental sensors,
360-degree Lidar, and cameras.
When you log in, everything
will look and feel
as though you were
actually there,
except all the people
will be replaced
with virtual inhabitants.
So let's start with
the balloon drones.
I'm going to build them
with Android Things
as a software platform, and add
TensorFlow models to control
the autonomous flight and
privacy algorithms, that'll
remove people from
the camera images.
We're going to send those
images and the Lidar data
into Google Cloud
Storage buckets
and use Pub/Sub to
send notifications
about those new uploads
to a specialized,
containerized application
hosted as a Kubernetes service.
That will spin up,
or horizontally
scale as many copies
of my application
called pods, that
I need to process
the incoming queue of images.
The rank and scale
of incoming imagery
will vary over time, effectively
creating a queue of data
to be processed.
We can use preemptible VMs
here to save significant costs.
The real-time sensor data
will also use Pub/Sub.
This time to publish,
stream, and throttle data
from each sensor, guaranteeing
its delivered into Dataflow.
Dataflow is a serverless,
fully-managed data processing
service that lets us
use the Apache Beam
SDKs to perform
continuous computation
over an incoming data stream.
We're going to use it
here to create a moving
window over the data,
combining the results
of multiple, nearby drones
over a fixed period,
to calculate an
accurate topographic map
of environmental conditions
which it will then
publish as a new Pub/Sub
stream, which in turn, triggers
another Kubernetes service.
This container
behind the service
is designed to process the
environmental sensor readings,
also using preemptible VMs
to create our virtual climate
and weather.
The process results from both
Kubernetes and Alpha Services
are then stored in Spanner.
Spanner's strong consistency
and horizontal scalability
is critical in a
virtual environment that
can be modified by
both real-world changes
and changes made by
globally distributed users.
Another Kubernetes service
takes all the virtual world data
and combines it to construct
a server-based interactive
virtual environment.
The client side is
built as an Android app.
The app will have a
Daydream UI to provide
the immersive environment.
We'll keep an open socket with
the server to receive updates.
And we'll send
back any changes we
make to apply them
server-side to Spanner,
so that it can then be
reflected across all
of the other clients.
The speech recognition
and Translate API
is, in short, everyone
in the virtual earth
can communicate in real
time, no matter what
their native language.
And finally, we send all the
user analytics to BigQuery.
We use streaming
inserts, so we can
analyze how people
are interacting
with that virtual earth,
and create a Data Studio
dashboard to keep track
of current usage patterns
over time.
There you have it.
Do you want to escape a world
in which red balloons float
on every street corner?
Try my virtual world.
COLT MCANLIS: Well, all right.
Nice to see you go
first for a change.
How'd that feel?
RETO MEIER: It felt good.
It was nice not
to be constrained
by your architecture
for a change.
You ready to take a swing?
COLT MCANLIS: Listen, I got paid
for the better part of a decade
to make video games.
Let's get this party started.
Now, my build isn't
expecting you to run around
in a realistic 3D environment.
If Reto had ever
read any real sci-fi,
he'd know that's
not how this works.
In real sci-fi, they
sit down, jack in,
and start running around
in a virtual space.
So that's what we're
going to build--
a virtual space.
My metaverse is a
virtual reality MMORPG.
Your player can
explore the wonders
of my beautifully rendered
fantasy world with a pet dragon
by your side.
My world looks better
than the real world,
so we don't care about
Reto's real world.
And we're going to
ditch all the sensor
stuff that's used to create
those 3D environments.
Yes, even the real-time
weather stuff.
See, if I live in Seattle
and it rains all the time,
the last thing I
want to do is go
into a game where it's raining.
So let's get rid of all of that.
Now, I like the Babel Fish
idea of translation and speech.
That's actually super cool.
So I'm going to
table that for now,
so we can get to
the meat of things.
This leaves us with a
few overlapping pieces.
First off, yeah, got
to agree that Daydream
running on Android is
the best place for this.
However, Daydream by itself
is not a proper game engine.
I'm going to use Unity to act
as a client-side game code
interface between the user
and the Daydream system.
This also means that for our
coding, scripting, and artwork,
they'll all be in a file format
that Unity can understand.
Now, we're going to roll
the dice on this one
and say that, along with
our content generation,
we'll end up with some
sort of system or governing
body that decides how and
where new zones and regions are
added.
We're also going to need an
update staging area, where
new content and fixes
can be stored and pushed
to the clients and servers.
We'll use a
combination of Spanner
and cloud storage to hold both
the relational items as well
as the binary data.
We'll also put in a
GCF frontend, which
allows the client
to check for updates
and get a list of
the things it needs
to connect to in cloud storage
to download and update.
And just to make sure that
you are who you say you are,
we're going to add an App
Engine frontend instance, which
will leverage cloud IAM to
authenticate and identify
the user and communicate
with the account management
database, which may include
some sensitive information
like billing and contact data.
For my application, we're
going with App Engine Flex.
For some services, I can just
use the provided run times,
but I can also customize it
with my own Docker images
if we need some
specific functionality.
By the way, this whole
thing is very important
if we're trying to make a
metaverse-level game engine.
As a user enters
a game zone, we'll
figure out their closest
region that we're deployed in
and connect them directly
to a world shard that's
backed by a GAE Flex instance.
These world shards
will help align things
like player and NPC movement and
keep all the attached clients
coordinated, so you don't see
people clipping through walls.
Now, along with that, we'll have
a separate game service, which
is hosted on another cluster.
This is responsible for things
like trades, auction houses,
guilds, and some basic types
of combat organization.
To accomplish all
that, we'll synchronize
the state between the
instances, using the awesomeness
of Cloud Spanner.
Now, another great reason
to use App Engine Flex is it
has horizontal
scaling, without having
to worry about cluster
resource constraints.
So that, combined
with Spanner, means
that I can scale to
the levels I need,
without having to
page a bunch of SREs
to punch a hole in
the wall and plug
in new servers in the
middle of the night.
Now, for situations where we're
using custom Docker images,
we'll also add a path to
the Container Registry
to host new container images
to be used for these services.
Otherwise, we can handle
service code deployments
through standard
rollout processes.
Now, finally, let's
add that chat service.
Much like Reto's
build, I like the idea
of adding auto translation
systems in there.
I actually think he
got that part right.
So there you have it.
A somewhat modern approach
to building, scaling,
updating, and interacting with
a massive metaverse environment.
And with the time I
have left, let's talk
about how to add things
like microtransactions,
in-game advertisements,
and a hot key
that'll bring food to your
door, so you don't even
have to leave the game.
RETO MEIER: Just couldn't
resist, could you?
COLT MCANLIS: I'm a
creature of habit.
RETO MEIER: Now, it's
your turn to decide
which build was better--
my transformative rendering of
our world, a boon to science,
and knowledge,
and understanding,
and Colt's mildly
addictive MMORPG.
COLT MCANLIS: Your
build was so convoluted,
I was expecting you to put
a 3D printer inside VR.
In any case, it's not up to us.
It's up to you, the viewer.
Leave a comment below the video
to say which one of our builds
is better.
And don't forget to check
out the "Build Out" podcast,
where we take a deep
dive into the technology
behind these builds.
RETO MEIER: Thanks for watching.
I'm Reto Meier.
COLT MCANLIS: And
I'm Colt McAnlis.
Always remember, perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]